this is london's financial center
the city of london at 1 pm around
half a million people work here well
not anymore the covert 19 pandemic has
changed our relationship with the office
perhaps forever millions of white collar
workers
have seen they don't have to be married
to a regimented commute to work
at your desk by nine system instead
they have found they can have a more
open relationship with the office
but the effects of that change are
significant streets like this which at
rush hour you could barely squeeze down
and now quiet and inside these towers
it's the same situation although after
the pandemic things will get busier
it's not clear they will return to the
way they were
survey after survey shows workers want
flexibility
but more surprisingly managers and
bosses are listening and many are
joining the push for flexible work
so are these changes here to stay and if
they
are what does that mean for the office
and those of us who work in them
[Music]
during the covert lockdown there's been
a schism
between those who've realized wait i
need the office
like me and those who are happy to spend
less time there
like my co-producer tom when i take a
coffee break i get to see my
three-year-old and that is
that is great um i've enjoyed that a lot
um
and you know i i'm also kind of
fortunate i have a good microphone here
i have a camera from work i can
you know move it around and you know
hide my mess
in time to do an interview like it it
has worked
pretty well for me um to do my job and
do it in this
sort of isolated workstation that i've
created
i live in a shared flat where
it's hard to be productive and
given the choice between an office with
a desk and
free coffee and and all the rest it's a
simple choice
i like being in the office it just has
to be different for different people
right
different people have different
struggles and different people
you know find an office as a solution or
find the office as a as a part of that
struggle
[Music]
the covid pandemic has forced a radical
experiment
on us and the results of that experiment
are coming in
companies now know if employees can work
remotely
they know if teams are still being
productive
and workers have gotten a taste for
flexibility
and they like it before
the paradigm in the office world was i'm
going to the office
nine to five and if not i have to
explain why or i'm doing something
unusual
now i know that i can stay home one or
two days a week or that i could come at
different hours and that impacts overall
demand
draw polig is an author and property
advisor to some of the world's biggest
companies he argues things aren't going
back to the way they were
deal with it i think at some point
things change fundamentally you know
there's a difference between employees
being away our office is being empty for
two or three months
and between offices being empty for a
year or 15 months like you just don't go
back to the same place after such
such a length of period
draw argues workers have adjusted
they've got new routines and habits
so what will become the new normal
surveys show
workers are splitting their time between
the office and home
and want to keep it that way management
like the idea too
a uk survey of over 2000 office workers
found most do not intend to spend five
days a week in the workplace
even when the pandemic is over with both
bosses and employees seeing home working
as a long-term
trend a survey by business consultancy
mckenzie
of 800 global executives found
15 will allow staff to work remotely two
or more days a week in the finance
sector
the netherlands biggest bank predicts
that staff will be working about
half their time from home once the
pandemic is
over and in italy uni credit plans to
have 40 percent of work done remotely
after the crisis it's important to say
this shift is not being seen across the
economy
in the us more than 60 percent of
workers cannot work remotely
their jobs require at least some
physical presence
but for millions of white collar workers
the scale
and speed of this change should not be
underestimated
in a prime market like new york or
london or san francisco or even shanghai
or hong kong
a company spends between twelve thousand
to twenty thousand dollars a year on
putting
an employee in a seat in an office now
one of the most interesting questions
that i think companies
will ask themselves now is not okay can
i save money by you know
telling everyone to go home but they can
ask themselves
if i take fifteen thousand dollars and
spend it differently
can i make my employee more productive
can i make my employee happier
can i maybe attract better people than i
currently have and i think in many cases
the answer to that question will be yes
draw believes we are living through
nothing short of a revolution
in the way we use offices and there are
going to be winners
and losers to destabilize office and to
cause a revolution
you only need 10 or 15 percent of demand
to shift
and i think that's what's happening jack
there's been recent survey data that
you've got hold of about
occupancy rates around here what are
they like are these buildings
practically empty
yeah i mean they're certainly more than
half empty jack citizens bloomberg's
european commercial property reporter
and he's been told privately what
commercial real estate agencies
won't say publicly if you were speaking
to them
off the record then you you detect a
much more significant amount of concern
and actually you see it with some of the
public statements you've seen real
estate leaders
come out and say publicly look we need
to get people back
come on you know come on politicians you
need to sort this out
so those of you who are feeling very
comfortable never coming back into the
office
well bad news experts agree that for
most of us
we will still have a relationship with
the office just
not as demanding but even if workers
return four out of five work days that's
still
a huge reduction and it's got investors
attention
what you see if you look at the share
prices of the of the big office
landlords
is that they're you know they're down
substantially this year
um much the london the big london office
landlords are down
30 40 50 this year but the valuation of
their assets
has barely changed it's likely that both
of those numbers are wrong
and it'll be you know somewhere in
between
with growing consensus that office
workers will be splitting their time
between the office
and perhaps their home flexible
workspaces
find themselves well positioned to take
advantage
tanya adir is the co-founder and ceo of
uncommon a london-based flexible working
company founded in 2015.
she agrees things aren't going back to
the way they were
but sees a bright future for the office
it's very difficult to run a team if
people are completing different
locations yes you can work from home you
can work from a coffee shop one day a
week
but at the same time to really have that
connection between individuals where i
think
ideas come to life you do want to be
present in physical space together
tanya is betting officers will shift
from being
primarily places where you go to get
work done to places where you go
to collaborate and build teams you don't
necessarily need to go to the office you
don't need to waste the time of
commuting
the reasons for that office to exist are
fundamentally to come
and meet your um you know your
colleagues collaborate be able to
come together and and work on the
presentation on a new idea
to you know exchange sort of um energies
fundamentally with you know with each
other
this trend of making offices places for
collaboration has been going on for
years
but the covert pandemic has shifted the
dial
the argument's not around will work be
more flexible
it's about how flexible it will be
the office of the future is not a place
the office of the future is a network
that allows me to enable my employees
to access whatever it is that they need
to access right now in order to produce
their best possible work and of course
to be happy and to keep coming back
and to give their talents to my business
and not to anyone else
tanya agrees that satellite offices will
become more common
but argues for most of us the office
will still play a major role
naturally when everything normalizes
people would want to still have their
headquarters their culture their
identity to be able to connect and
i think there is a very loud voice out
there saying we're all very productive
from home
but i think there is a silent majority
that are not that productive at home and
they just
you know they're not being silly hurt
because your kids are around
your pet is disturbing you your you know
neighbor is doing
decoration renovation and and you know
making noise
[Music]
after a year of working from home the
gloss may have come off
and many of us will start to miss the
office
but will anyone bosses or workers
really want to go back to the old ways
offices aren't going to stay like this a
ghost town
but instead of cramming us in the new
office may well be spacier
with more room to collaborate and most
importantly
we will come in when we need to not
because we have to
you